ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะคุณหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าคะวันนี้วัน
อะไร
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะใช้ขั้นที่ 3 เดือนอะไร
คะเดือนเมษายน
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพต 2  5  6 ห้า
ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะกะเมื่อวานนี้
วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันเสาร์วันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่ 2 ค่ะเรียนอะไรคะเดือน
เมษายน
เมื่อปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วันจันทร์
อ้าววันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 4 ค่ะเดือน
เมษายน
ปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะแล้วตอน
นี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าเวลา 4:00 น
ตี 4 นาที
04:51 นาทีค่ะตี 4
51 นาทีเป็นตอนเช้าเนาะ
เป็นตอนแล้วก็เป็นกลางเมื่อคืนใช่ไหมคะ
กลางคืนนี้
มืดภาษาไทยพูดว่าเช้ามืด 4:00 นะคะเพราะ
ไม่เป็นตอนกลางคืนใช่ไหมคะ
เป็นยังไงบ้างคะผู้หญิงตอนนี้แล้วจะพอ
เหลือหัดตื่นมาเจอครูฝาเลย
ตื่นเธอกูมาตอนเช้ายายคะว่าตอนตี 4 เนี่ย
อ๋อตี 4 นะคะตี 4 กว่าพระอาทิตย์
ยังไม่ขึ้นใช่ไหมมีพระจันทร์สวยมีดวง
จันทร์หรือว่ามีพระจันทร์จังหวัดครูฟ้า
เราภูฟ้าแบบเห็นพระจันทร์แน่ผู้ฟ้าแบบคิด
ถึงอะไรหรอเห็นพระจันทร์คิดถึงฤดูอะไร
ฤดูเวลาเห็นพระจันทร์ใช่มั้ยฤดูใบไม้ร่วง
ไหมใช่ค่ะขอดูใบไม้ร่วงก็คือต้นไม้ใช่ไหม
ต้นไม้เนี่ยมันก็จะมีใบไม้เนาะแล้วก็ใบ
ไม้เนี่ยนะคะมันร่วงมันร่วงก็จะมีใบไม้ใบ
ไม้ใบไม้ที่พื้นเยอะๆเนาะฤดูใบไม้ร่วง
ประเทศไทยมีไหมคะ
ไม่มีค่ะไม่มีว่าใบไม้ร่วงทุกฤดูนั้น
ประเทศไทยๆใส่
ใบไม้ร่วงเนาะประเทศนักเรียนเนี่ยมีฤดูใบ
ไม้ร่วงเนาะหายหาใช่ฤดูใบไม้ร่วงเนี่ยโอ
ประเทศอะไรยึดยุโรปก็มีใช่ไหมเกาหลี
ญี่ปุ่นจีนหรือใกล้ให้อื่นๆนะคะเหนื่อย
รักเซเรียนิวซีแลนด์แต่เวลาอาจจะไม่ตรง
กันแต่ประเทศนักเรียนมีฤดูใบไม้ร่วง
สีฟ้าเวลาครูฟ้าเนี่ยพูดถึงฤดูใบไม้ร่วง
ครูหญิงก็ต้องถึงใบไม้ค่ะครูฟ้าอ่ะเอ้า
ผู้หญิงไหนคะใบไม้อะไรได้แต่ไม่ใช่ใบไม้
สีเขียว
เอ้า
คือไหมอันนี้เป็นใบไม้นะคะครูฟ้ารู้ไหมคะ
ว่าใบอะไร
ใบเมเปิ้ลได้ใบเมเปิ้ลน้อแต่ฤดูใบไม้ร่วง
เนี่ยใบเมเปิ้ลสีเขียวอันนี้คือใบไม้มัน
ร่วงเนาะอ้าวลบแล้วนะคะใบไม้ร่วงลงมา
เนี่ยมันร่วงลงมาแล้วมันใบไม้ทับกันมัน
ถ่ายคร่าวๆก็เยอะๆนะคะมีใบไม้สีแดงใช่ไหม
ใบไม้สีแดงแต่ว่าฤดูใบไม้ร่วงนี่ไงคะอัน
นี้คือใบไม้มันกำลังร่วงโรย
โอ้มันกำลังร่วงลงมาสวยเนาะๆอ่ะครูหญิง
ทำไมสวยจังเลยนี่ใช่ไหมคะครูหญิงกับครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยก็เลยคิดถึงใบไม้ที่เป็นสีแดงสี
เหลือง
สีส้มอะไรๆหมายที่ไม่ใช่สีเขียว
ไงเนี่ยมีใบไม้เนาะจริงได้ยินเสียงไหมคะ
เสียงเข้าไหมไม่มีค่ะไม่มีนะคะโอเค Miss
My  Mind สีเขียวสมัยใบไม้สีเหลืองใบไม้
สีแดง
แต่ก็ก็ใบไม้สีน้ำตาล
ไอหาใบไม้ร่วงนะสวยมากนะอะไรว่างๆเนี่ยดู
สิครูฟ้าโอ้ว
ใบไม้เราบอกว่าว่าใบไม้เปลี่ยนสีใช่ไหมคะ
อ่ะ
อันนี้อ่อนแรงใบไม้สีอะไรโทรฟ้าสีเขียว
ค่ะแล้วมันเปลี่ยนเป็นสีอะไรคะสีเหลืองสี
เหลืองแล้วก็เปลี่ยนเป็นสีอะไรคะอีส้ม
แล้วก็เปลี่ยนเป็นสีอะไรคะสีแดงแล้วก็สี
สุดท้ายเปลี่ยนเป็นสีอะไรคะสีน้ำตาลสีน้ำ
ตาลนะเราบอกว่าเวลาเราคิดถึงฤดูใบไม้ร่วง
แล้วก็ต้องคิดถึงใบไม้มั้ยแล้วก็ใบไม้
เนี่ยเปลี่ยนสีนะคะใบไม้เปลี่ยนสี
แล้วคิดถึงอะไรอีกหรอคะผู้หญิงนอกจากใบ
ไม้แล้วนี่ค่ะ
เวลาฤดูใบไม้ร่วงก็ต้องคิดถึงอันนี้เลย
ค่ะครูฟ้า
ฟักทองหรอ
God ท้องอ่ะอุ้ย
ทำไมเป็นฟักทองล่ะสีส้มเหิมสีส้ม
ไม่เกี่ยวไม่เกี่ยวนะไม่ใช่ใบไม้หรือใช่
มั้ยใบไม้มีหลายๆสีแล้วก็มีฟักทองเพราะ
ว่าฤดูใบไม้ผลิสมัยสปริงและฤดูใบไม้ผลิ
เนี่ยนักเรียนก็ปลูกต้นไม้
จะแล้วก็ฤดูร้อนแล้วฟักทองเดี๋ยวก็โตโตๆ
คอฤดูใบไม้ร่วงก็เป็นฟักทองมีฟักทอง
[เพลง]
แล้วก็สีส้มด้วยนักเตะติดจ่ายแล้วก็มีอีก
อย่างนึงไงครูฟ้าทำไมฤดูใบไม้ร่วงนะฤดูใบ
ไม้ร่วงเราคิดถึงฟักทองทำไมคะผู้หญิงมี
อะไรอีกติดต่อ
นี่ค่ะมีฮาโรวีน
และฤดูใบไม้ร่วงก็จะมีฮาโลวีน halloween
ก็มีฟักทอง
ฮาโลวีนวันที่เท่าไหร่นะฮะรายปีเนี่ยมั้ย
ตุลาคมฮาโรวีนนะคะวันที่เอากินข้าวสีอะไร
ก็จะได้เห็นชัดๆสี 3
ตุลาคมใช่มั้ยถ้าในแบบอเมริกายุโรป
ญี่ปุ่นเนี่ยก็จะเป็นฤดูใบไม้ร่วงนะคะก็
จะคิดถึงฮาโรวีน
ผิดนะแล้วมันฮาโลวีนในก็จะเป็นสีส้มด้วย
นะเป็นสีส้มใจ
นะคะแล้วใบไม้ก็ร่วงหมดแล้วเหลือแค่ต้น
ไม้ซึ่งมีกี่ครูฟ้าฤดูใบไม้ร่วงเนี่ย
ประเทศไทยเราไม่มีใช่ไหมค่ะเราก็จะแบบ
เอ๊ะฤดูใบไม้ร่วงอ่าเดี๋ยวเราจะคิดถึง
อะไรได้อีกผู้หญิงก็ไม่เจอมาใน
อินเตอร์เน็ตทรูฟ้าในคะหญิงเจออะไรคิดถึง
อะไรค่ะ
นี่สิอันนี้
อันนี้เนี่ยไม่ใช่อันนี้นะคะไม่ใช่ฟักทอง
นะนี่อันนี้อันนี้
กลุ่ม
อะไรนะคนไทยเรียกว่าอะไรนะคะหุ่นไล่กา
ใช่ค่ะแล้วจะมีนกใช่ไหมนกสีดำๆอีกาเนี่ย
พอมันบินมาแล้วมันเห็น
มันก็กลัวเพราะวันคิดว่าเป็นของอะไรนะคะ
กูม้าชอบผิดไหนอยู่
ขึ้นนกก็กลัวหุ่นไล่กานะคะซอยหุ่นไล่กา
ว่าคนเห็นกูมาเห็นอย่างควายก็ไปดีกว่า
ภูฟ้าเห็นตอนกลางคืนตอนกลางคืนเนี่ยมีพระ
จันทร์มีดาวเท่าพูดเห็นตอนกลางคืนครูบาก็
กลัวเมาร้องให้ถ่ายแต่ในรูปเนี่ยเป็นตอน
กลางวันก็ก็โอเคใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะคุณไล่กา
ว่าไล่กาจ่ายหน้าการนกกาก้าตาขาไงก็ไล่ไป
ไปไล่หุ่นไล่กาสาย
โอ้โหผู้หญิงทุนรายการเนี่ยจะอยู่ในฤดูใบ
ไม้ร่วงใช่ไหมใส่ไข่ไหมต้นไม้เนี่ยสี
เขียวแล้วก็เปลี่ยนสีเปลี่ยนสีไหมเป็นฤดู
ใบไม้ร่วงแล้วก็มีอีกนะคะครูฟ้าฤดูใบไม้
ร่วงมีอะไรอีกคะครูหญิงฤดูใบไม้ร่วงเนี่ย
ผู้หญิงคิดถึงอะไรนี่เขาบอกว่าฤดูใบไม้
ร่วงและก็จะมี
แอปเปิ้ล
สโนว์ไวท์นี่จะถูก
App  Are โอ๊ยทำไมรูปแบบกินแอปเปิ้ลล่ะ
แก้วเหมือนฟักทองไงทำไมประเทศนักเรียน
เนี่ยฤดูใบไม้ผลิในประเทศนักเรียนก็จะ
เริ่มจากฤดูสมุดอัดเรียนนี้ใช่ไหมเดือน
เมษายน
ประเทศนักเรียนในก็จะเป็นฤดูใบไม้ผลิมี
ดอกไม้มีใบไม้หน้าหานักเรียนก็จะปลูกปลูก
ต้นไม้ใช่ไหมคะพอฤดูร้อนทำไมต้นไม้ก็โตโต
ๆพอฤดูใบไม้ร่วงค่ะเนาะเนาะไก่ไม้ร่วง
เนี่ยก็มีแอปเปิ้ลแล้วก็เก็บแล้วก็กินได้
พอดีไงก็จะมีแอปเปิ้ลแอปเปิ้ลเป็นคนละไม้
ในฤดูใบไม้ร่วง
ผู้หญิงโอ้ยเปิ้ลเยอะเลยอ่ะฮะครูฟ้าชอบ
กินอ่ะรึแอปเปิ้ลใช่ไหมคะ
ว่ากินแอปเปิ้ลทุกหน้ามันเลยกูม้าแล้วถ้า
เป็นประเทศไทยอ่ะประเทศไทยเนี่ยก็มี
แอปเปิ้ลนะมีต้นต้นแอปเปิ้ลประเทศไทยมี
แอปเปิ้ลฤดูอะไร
ประเทศไทยมีแอปเปิ้ลฤดู
ร้อนไหมหรือหน้าหนาว
มากินทุกฤดูนะคะจ่ายค่ะแต่ไปแน่ไทยเนี่ย
ถ้าจะมีแอปเปิ้ลแอปเปิ้ลแอปเปิ้ลแอปเปิ้ล
มากๆก็ฤดูหนาวหนาว
ผู้บ้านอกจาก Apple นะฤดูใบไม้ร่วงเนี่ย
ยังมีอันนี้ค่ะมีอะไรอีกคะคุณหญิง
นี่ค่ะอันนี้ก็เป็นผลไม้เหมือนกันครูฟ้า
รู้ไหมว่าผลไม้อันนี้เรียกว่าอะไร
เหมือนองุ่นเลยนะอ่า
ขอดูเบอร์รี่บลูเบอร์รี่หรือว่าพวก
เบอร์รี่สวยประเทศนักเรียนเนี่ยเวลาฤดูใบ
ไม้ร่วงก็จะมีเบอร์ดี้เยอะๆบางครั้งเนี่ย
คนไทยก็ไปสวีเดนไปนอร์เวย์ไปเก็บเบอร์รี่
แล้วก็ได้เงิน
หรืออันนี้ไม่ได้ได้ค่ะได้
ปริได้เยอะใช่ไหม
บลูเบอร์รี่คู่หญิงชอบกินไหมคะตอบมามาก
ค่ะครูฟ้าชอบไหมคะบลูเบอร์รี่ฟ้าชอบ
ลูเบอร์รี่มากแต่ว่ากูมาไม่ได้กิน
บลูเบอร์รี่แบบเนี้ยแบบ
ว่ากินแยมบลูเบอร์รี่
โดนัทลูเบอร์รี่ทุกอย่าง Everything ที่
มันบลูเบอร์รี่ฟ้าชอบมากแต่ไม่ได้กินก็
ไม่กินบลูเบอร์รี่เป็นอยากบลูเบอร์รี่แบบ
นี้ทั่วประเทศไทยเนี่ยแพงมากนะคะแบบบาง
ครั้งหนึ่งแพ้จะ 1 แพ็คเล็กๆนะแพ็คเล็กๆ
เนี่ย
200 บาทนักเรียนเห็นไงสีก็คือ
กลืนเมื่อไหร่นัดสองร้อยนะคะ 200 บาทนะดู
เบอร์รี่เล็กนะคะมีนิดหน่อยมีแบบกินกิน
กินหนึ่งวันหมดแล้วประเทศไทยเนี่ย
บลูเบอร์รี่แพงมาก
นะแต่ว่าแยมบลูเบอร์รี่เยอะมากจ่ายค่ะ
เพราะมีบลูเบอร์รี่นิดหน่อยเนาะ
ครูบาฟ้าหลั่ง
นอกจากบลูเบอร์รี่แอปเปิ้ลฟักทองแล้วยัง
มีอะไรอีกคะผู้หญิงมีนี่ค่ะโอ้
อันนี้คือเขาเรียกว่าอะไรข้า
คะใช่ค่ะพลาดใช่กูสังกฤษคราดช่วยเพราะว่า
ฤดูใบไม้ร่วงเนี่ยใบไม้เนาะบ่ายๆเนี่ย
มันก็ร่วงใช่ไหมร่วงร่วงร่วงลงพื้นเนี่ย
เยอะเออมากๆทำไมนักเรียนเนี่ยก็ต้องเอา
คราสนะคะอันนี้นะเนี่ยคราดเนี่ยมักคราด
คราดคราดใบไม้
[เพลง]
กวาดใบไม้นะใช่ค่ะกวาดใบไม้คือคนไทยอ่ะคน
ไทยจะมีไม้กวาดนะเป็นไม้กว่า
ไปกว่านะฮะ
อะไรคะนี่ไปกวาดก็
หมายควายแล้วก็กวาดไปกวาดมานะ
นักเรียนบอกว่าไม่วันนี้เข้าใจครูหญิงวาด
รูปอะไร
เรียนผู้หญิงวาดรูปไม้กวาดผู้หญิงว่ารูป
ไม้กวาดไงเนี่ยมันจะประมาณนี้นะครับ
ประมาณนี้นะไม้กวาด
แต่ประเทศนักเรียนเนี่ยไม่ได้ต้องใช้คราด
เนาะคนไทยไม่ค่อยใช้คลาดและค่อยอ่ะค่ะ
เพราะว่ามันไม่ได้คนไทยต้องกว่ากว่ากว่า
คนไทยไม่มีหญ้าสมัยประเทศนักเรียนและมี
ต้นหญ้าเนี่ยต้นหญ้าต้นหญ้าต้นหญ้าก็ต้อง
ใช้คราดหน้าใจคลาดน้องในฤดูใบไม้ร่วง
เนี่ยเราก็เลยคิดถึงคลาดด้วย
น้าในการกวาดใบไม้
บ้านไม้มีอะไรอีกคะผู้หญิงฤดูใบไม้ร่วง
อ่ะฮาโรวีนไปแล้วเนาะนี่ค่ะครูปารู้ไหม
ว่าอันนี้คืออาไร๊ไก่
ไก่อะไรไก่นกยูง
ไก่งวงไก่งวงไงเพราะไก่อันนี้อาจจะแค่
อเมริกามั้งเนาะอเมริกาเนี่ยก็จะมี Thank
You วิ่งใช่ไหมแต่งกี่ปีอ่ะ Thank  You
วิ่งอย่าก็จะกินไก่งวงรหาขอบช่วงแบบฤดูใบ
ไม้ร่วงก็อาจจะมีไก่งงแบบกำลังโตโตแล้วก็
ไก่งวงมาแล้วก็กินนะคะ
ประเทศไทยไม่มีนะคะไก่งวงและมีไม่พี่ไม่
มีแล้วใครเงินตัวยิ่งใหญ่นะตัวใหญ่นะไม่
เหมือนไก่ประเทศไทยในประเทศให้ตัวเล็กมาก
ไก่งวงไงวะอันนี้อันนี้คือไก่ประเทศไทยนะ
คะเราต้องไก่ม่วงก็คือแบบใหญ่มากน้องแต่
รึขอใบไม้ร่วงเนี่ยนะคะเราก็คิดถึงไก่งวง
เนาะใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงแล้วก็วันนี้
เนี่ยหมดเวลาแล้วใช่มั้ยจ่ายค่ะนักเรียน
นะคิดถึงอะไรหรือว่าประเทศนักเรียนในฤดู
ใบไม้ร่วงมีอะไรที่ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ไม่ได้พูดนะคะก็คอมเม้นท์บอกได้ครูหญิง
กับครูฟ้าจะได้รู้ในห่างส่วนวันนี้นะคะ
เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนแล้วแล้วเจอกันวีดีโอ
หน้าสวัสดีค่ะ